كيف سيعمل هذا بالضبط ،
وهل سينتج
عنه افتتاح جميع هذه الشركات الأجنبية
لمقر إقليمي في المملكة
حسنًا ، أقول لك آه روزماري إن
نافذة الثلاث سنوات هي جدول زمني قصير جدًا
هنا وهذه خطوة جريئة
لإجبار يد  تلك
الشركات العالمية التي لها
مقارها الإقليمية بشكل أساسي في دبي ،
لذلك
دعونا نهيئ المشهد هنا حيث أن محمد بن
سلمان هو ولي العهد منذ عام
2017 وقد منحه والده الملك سلمان السلطة
الكاملة هنا للدفع من
خلال هذا التنوع
بعيدًا عن النفط وإنشاء
لم يتم الإعلان عن الوظائف التي تتحدث عنها على
أنها تحدٍ مباشر لدبي ، لكنها
بالتأكيد في هذه المنطقة تُرى بهذه
الطريقة
ولكن علينا أن نضعها في السياق ، حيث أن
الإمارات العربية
المتحدة تبني هذه البنية التحتية
منذ 30 عامًا.  يربط
بين الروابط التجارية
إنشاء الأنظمة الطبية وسياحة الأنظمة المدرسية
والأحداث الكبرى ، ليس من السهل
في هذه النافذة التي تبلغ مدتها ثلاث سنوات أن يكون ولي
العهد  تهدف إلى
سحب ذلك بعيدًا ، لا يمكنني رؤية الشركات التي
تبطل العلاقات التي
تربطها هنا في دبي والآن في أبو ظبي على مدار
العقد الماضي وكذلك من حيث
بنائها ،
لذلك يجب أن يكون هناك نوع من الحل الوسط ،
نعم أنا  سيكون لها وجود في المملكة
العربية السعودية ، هل سأنسحب من الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
فأنا لا أرى ذلك الآن ولكن هناك
بعض الحوافز التي تجعل هذه الشركات
لتكون في المملكة العربية السعودية ،
فهي أكبر اقتصاد في
المنطقة منذ فترة
طويلة ولديها  أكبر عدد سكاني في
الواقع أكبر من دول الخليج الخمس الأخرى
هنا في المنطقة أه
مجتمعة ويظل
المصدر الأول للنفط حول العالم لذا
بينما يحاول الابتعاد عن
هذه الهيدروكربونات
والدخول في صناعات أخرى هنا وجلب
الشركات إليها  لا يزال لديه تلك القوة
ليكون المصدر الأول في العالم
للنفط ولديه
الاحتياطيات المؤكدة رقم واحد في نفس
الوقت إكليل الجبل هذا هو التحدي هنا
هذا ليس الجزرة للشركات
أه معظم المراقبين أنا  بلغ الذروة لنقول إن
هذا هو لي الذراع ونحاول
إجبار الشركات على القيام بذلك أه لا
تسير بسلاسة وهذه علامة استفهام كبيرة
نوع آخر من
التحرك الجريء من قبل ولي العهد ولكن
هل تحقق النتائج
فهي ليست كذلك  أكيد لكن هذا مؤكد